ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень». мене звати Джон Ватус, я технічний директор з освіти в IBM
Quantum. це 10-й урок серії та другий урок третього розділу, який присвячено загальній
формулюванню квантової інформації. цей урок про канали, які описують зміни в
системах, що зберігають квантову інформацію. це включає корисні операції, наприклад ті, що виконуються
унітарними gate'ами та квантовими circuit'ами, а також зміни, яких ми можемо хотіти уникнути, наприклад шум. ми також можемо описувати вимірювання
як канали, і це ми розглянемо в наступному уроці. термін «канал» прийшов до нас із
теорії інформації, яка, серед іншого, вивчає інформаційну ємність зашумлених комунікаційних
каналів. тож коли ми думаємо про канали, ми мислимо абстрактно про комунікаційні
канали. може здатися дивним розглядати складне обчислення як комунікаційний канал, але нам потрібне
слово, яке позначатиме загальне поняття процесу, що певним чином змінює інформацію. і хоч як це дивно, слово
«канал» закріпилося — безсумнівно, багато в чому завдяки величезному впливу теорії інформації і зокрема
роботи Клода Шеннона у 1940-х роках на квантову інформацію та обчислення. ось огляд
уроку. ми почнемо з основ, включно з визначенням поняття каналу, а також з тим, як унітарні операції у спрощеному формулюванні
квантової інформації можна описати як канали. ми також поговоримо про те, що опуклі комбінації каналів є каналами. і якщо ти
дивуєшся, чому це поняття опуклості весь час виникає — тому що це справді фундаментально важливе математичне поняття в теорії
квантової інформації. ми також розглянемо деякі приклади каналів, зокрема qubit-канали, які знову з'являтимуться час
від часу протягом решти уроку. у другій частині уроку ми поговоримо про три різні способи представлення каналів
математично. зокрема ми поговоримо про представлення Штайнспрінга, представлення Краусса та представлення Чоя,
названі на честь трьох людей, чия робота була важливою у розвитку цих різних представлень. у третій та
заключній частині уроку ми розглянемо математичний доказ, який встановлює, що ці три представлення насправді еквівалентні, а також те, що вони
всі правильно характеризують визначення поняття каналу. це справді чудовий математичний доказ, на мій погляд, і сподіваюся, він додасть
ясності щодо цих різних представлень, їх зв'язку та принципів роботи. почнемо з основ і
відповімо на питання: що таке канали? як я вже зазначив на початку уроку, канали описують зміни —
зокрема дискретні зміни в часі в системах, що зберігають квантову інформацію. тут, коли ми говоримо про дискретну зміну в часі,
ми просто маємо на увазі зміну, яка відбувається між двома різними моментами часу, на відміну від
безперервного процесу, який, наприклад, має сенс розглядати протягом нескінченно малих часових проміжків. канали включають корисні операції, такі як
унітарні операції, що виконуються квантовими gate'ами та circuit'ами, а також зміни через шум. наприклад, для
цілей цього уроку ми переважно думатимемо про канали в абстрактних математичних термінах, і не буде особливої потреби
розрізняти корисне і некорисне. типові назви для каналів включають великі грецькі літери фі,
псі та дельта. ми використовуватимемо різні літери для позначення конкретних каналів. у простій ситуації, коли
ми маємо якусь систему, що перебуває у стані, описаному матрицею густини ро, і застосовуємо до цієї системи канал f,
результатом є система, чий стан описується матрицею густини фі від ро. отже, ми думаємо про заданий
канал фі як про функцію, що може застосовуватися до матриць густини певного розміру, або іншими словами —
матриць густини певної системи, до якої ми застосовуємо цей канал. є кілька вимог, яким канали повинні відповідати, щоб вважатися
дійсними каналами. по-перше, канали — це лінійні відображення. це повністю аналогічно ситуації, яку ми маємо як
у спрощеному формулюванні квантової інформації, де операції над квантовими векторами стану обов'язково лінійні,
так і в стандартному формулюванні класичної інформації, де ймовірнісні операції лінійні. ти міг би поставити під сумнів цю базову
вимогу лінійності, якщо дуже захочеш. але якщо ми хочемо теорію, сумісну як з теорією ймовірностей,
так і з вибором представляти квантові стани матрицями густини, то у нас немає вибору — ми просто маємо прийняти, що канали лінійні.
другою вимогою є те, що канали перетворюють матриці густини на матриці густини. це цілком логічно, адже якщо ми вибрали представляти
стани систем матрицями густини і застосовуємо канал до системи в якомусь стані, то результат повинен бути дійсним станом і тому
представленим матрицею густини. тут є дуже важливе доповнення: ця вимога
повинна виконуватися не лише тоді, коли ми застосовуємо канал до ізольованої системи, стан якої описується матрицею густини,
але й тоді, коли ми маємо складену систему, стан якої описується деякою матрицею густини, і застосовуємо канал лише до
частини цієї системи. отже, це вимоги, які ми висуваємо до каналів, і ми бачимо, що вони дуже
аналогічні вимогам до операцій як у спрощеному формулюванні квантової інформації, так і в стандартному формулюванні
класичної інформації. у спрощеному формулюванні квантової інформації операції представлені унітарними матрицями, оскільки вони
точно відповідають лінійним відображенням, що завжди перетворюють квантові вектори стану на квантові вектори стану для
заданої системи. аналогічно ймовірнісні операції представлені стохастичними матрицями, оскільки саме вони
завжди перетворюють вектори ймовірностей на вектори ймовірностей. тут ми працюємо з матрицями густини і є
ця додаткова вимога щодо складених систем, яка виявляється непотрібною для квантових векторів стану
або векторів ймовірностей. але загалом вимоги аналогічні і в певному сенсі нав'язані нам вибором
представляти квантові стани матрицями густини. ось деякі додаткові деталі про канали, включно з угодою
про те, як ми думатимемо про вхідні та вихідні системи каналу протягом уроку, а також більше деталей
про вимогу, що канали завжди перетворюють матриці густини на матриці густини. по-перше, кожен канал
має вхідну систему і вихідну систему. ми можемо називати ці системи як завгодно, але протягом
уроку я використовуватиму назву X для вхідної системи та назву Y для вихідної системи. концептуально канал
перетворює вхідну систему на вихідну, тому вхідна та вихідна системи ніколи не співіснують одночасно.
ми починаємо з X, застосовується або виконується канал, і в результаті X перетворилося на Y, чий стан
визначається лінійним відображенням, пов'язаним із каналом. вхідна та вихідна системи каналу не мають бути однаковими, і зокрема
вони не повинні мати однакову кількість класичних станів. однак може бути й так, що вхідна та вихідна системи є фактично однією системою, або іншими
WEBVTT
словами X дорівнює Y, і тоді ми просто уявляємо, що фі змінює стан системи. насправді це
дуже часта ситуація, яка нас цікавить. але ця можливість узгоджується з першим пунктом у тому сенсі, що ми ніколи не маємо
вхідну та вихідну системи як дві окремі системи одночасно. і в будь-якому разі для
цілей цього уроку зручно використовувати різні літери, а саме X і Y, для позначення вхідної та вихідної систем,
щоб не заплутатися. тепер розглянемо детальніше вимогу, що канали завжди перетворюють матриці густини
на матриці густини. припустімо, що ми вводимо нову систему Z. дамо
назву гамма множині класичних станів цієї нової системи. уявімо тепер, що ми утворюємо нову складену систему ZX,
що складається з нової системи разом із вхідною системою X каналу фі, і припустімо, що ця складена система перебуває у
стані, описаному матрицею густини ро. це може бути довільним квантовим станом цієї пари, але яким би він не був,
завжди можна виразити матрицю густини ро у формі, показаній на екрані, де обидва A і B
пробігають по множині класичних станів гамма, і кожна ро AB є деякою матрицею, рядки і стовпці якої відповідають будь-якій
множині класичних станів X. не потрібно давати назву цій множині класичних станів. щоб бути точним, кожна ро AB не обов'язково є
матрицею густини сама по собі, але вся матриця ро обов'язково є матрицею густини. коли ми застосовуємо канал фі до
системи X, вона перетворюється на Y, і ми залишаємось із парою ZY. спосіб, яким ми визначаємо
стан цієї пари після застосування фі лише до X, — це обчислення лінійного відображення фі для кожної з матриць ро A.
інший спосіб сказати це: ми беремо тензорний добуток відображення фі з тотожним відображенням на квадратних матрицях, рядки та стовпці яких
відповідають гамма, що своєю чергою відповідає нічого не робленню з новою системою Z. але це еквівалентний
опис, і він не вимагає вдаватися до деталей тензорних добутків відображень такого вигляду. вони
однак працюють досить прямолінійно, аналогічно до того, як вони працюють для векторів і матриць. один спосіб візуалізувати це —
через блокові матриці. якщо ми зробимо спрощувальне припущення, що множина класичних станів гамма складається з
цілих чисел від 0 до N мінус один для деякого натурального числа M, то стає легко записати все це, як
показано тут. і тепер повторимо вимогу, яку ми висуваємо до фі, щоб він був дійсним каналом: ми завжди маємо отримувати матрицю густини
з цього процесу, і це має бути правдою незалежно від вибору системи Z, а також
вибору ро, за умови що це матриця густини. може здатися досить суворою вимогою, і
може також здатися, що її дуже важко перевірити. але, як ми побачимо наприкінці уроку, вона насправді не така вже й сувора
або важка для перевірки. зокрема, ми маємо гарні математичні характеристики для цієї умови,
які пов'язані з різними представленнями, про які ми поговоримо пізніше. тепер розглянемо деякі приклади каналів,
починаючи з цілої категорії каналів, що називаються унітарними каналами. простими словами, це унітарні
операції, такі ж, як у спрощеному формулюванні квантової інформації, але розглянуті як канали. якщо точніше, припустімо, що U — унітарна
матриця, що представляє унітарну операцію на системі X. у спрощеному формулюванні квантової
інформації ми б множили цю матрицю на даний квантовий вектор стану, щоб визначити дію цієї операції на цей квантовий стан.
для матриць густини це працює так: ми множимо матрицю густини зліва на U і справа на U
дагер. математично ми називаємо цю операцію кон'югуванням матрицею U. це узгоджується з тим, що
|псі⟩⟨псі| є матрицею густини, що описує стан, представлений квантовим вектором стану |псі⟩. це досить
просто перевірити: зокрема, якщо ми застосуємо U до квантового вектора стану |псі⟩, то отримаємо U|псі⟩, і його
представлення матрицею густини задається цим вектором, помноженим на спряжений транспонований, тобто U|псі⟩⟨псі|U
дагер, коли ми обчислюємо спряжений транспонований від U|псі⟩. тож спосіб, яким визначається цей канал,
має сенс для чистих станів, і в поєднанні з лінійністю ми бачимо, що він має сенс і для матриць густини загалом,
оскільки кожну матрицю густини можна виразити як опуклу комбінацію чистих станів. це
визначення завжди дає нам дійсний канал для будь-якого унітарного оператора U. зокрема, кон'югування
унітарною матрицею не змінює слід матриці, і якщо ми кон'югуємо будь-яку напівдодатно визначену
матрицю будь-якою матрицею, ми отримаємо іншу напівдодатно визначену матрицю. це досить просто отримати
безпосередньо з визначення напівдодатно визначених матриць. тому матриці густини завжди відображаються на матриці густини,
і все це залишається правдою, навіть якщо ми беремо тензорний добуток U з тотожною матрицею будь-якого розміру, що еквівалентно
застосуванню цього каналу лише до частини складеної системи. ось дуже простий приклад унітарного каналу. припустімо,
що U сама по собі є тотожною матрицею. це очевидно дійсний канал, що називається тотожним каналом. нічого
не робити — це безумовно лінійна операція, і якщо ми почнемо з матриці густини і нічого з нею не робимо, то вона
залишиться матрицею густини. тому це дійсний канал. люди використовують різні символи для позначення цього каналу:
іноді це той самий символ, що й для тотожної матриці, що може трохи збивати з пантелику, але зазвичай не збиває. тут я використовую
літери ID скорочено від identity, щоб уникнути плутанини. це позначення також досить поширене. може здатися
дуже нудним каналом, але в контексті передачі інформації це насправді ідеальний канал, де
одержувач отримує саме те, що надіслав відправник, а це зазвичай те, чого хочуть найбільше в такому контексті. ще один спосіб
отримати багато прикладів каналів — брати опуклі комбінації каналів, або іншими словами усереднювати їх
між собою. те, що ми можемо це робити, є важливим аспектом каналів. щоб пояснити це детальніше, почнемо з двох каналів Ф0 та Ф1.
разом із дійсним числом p між 0 і одиницею. і щоб було зрозуміло, ми припускаємо, що ці два канали мають
однакову вхідну систему X, а також однакову вихідну систему Y. тепер розглянемо, що відбудеться, якщо ми вирішимо
застосувати перший канал Ф0 з імовірністю p, а інакше з імовірністю 1 мінус p —
другий канал Ф1. наприклад, ми могли б випадково обирати біт з цими ймовірностями, а потім використовувати цей випадковий
біт, щоб визначити, який канал застосовувати. роблячи це, ми фактично застосовуємо новий канал, який можемо назвати псі —
він задається опуклою комбінацією двох каналів, з яких ми починали, і може бути записаний так, як показано
на екрані. ми завжди можемо брати лінійні комбінації лінійних відображень таким чином. до речі, спосіб, яким лінійна
WEBVTT
комбінація лінійних відображень визначається на заданому вхіді, полягає в тому, що ми просто беремо ту саму лінійну комбінацію виходів.
це може виглядати тривіально, але це має сенс. вихід, який ми отримуємо з цього гіпотетичного сценарію, — це просто
зважене середнє виходів, які ми б отримали від двох початкових каналів. тим не менш це новий канал, і
якщо Ф0 та Ф1 були дійсними каналами, то це нове відображення також буде дійсним каналом. інший спосіб сказати
це математично: множина всіх каналів із заданої вхідної системи до заданої вихідної системи є
опуклою. це важлива математична властивість каналів. ми можемо робити це більш загально: якщо ми маємо M каналів Ф0 через Ф M мінус один
разом із вектором ймовірностей, що вказує ймовірність для кожного каналу, ми отримуємо новий канал шляхом відповідного усереднення каналів. тому
в певному сенсі це нескінченне джерело нових каналів. наприклад, клас так званих змішаних унітарних каналів — це те, що
ми отримуємо, беручи опуклі комбінації унітарних каналів. тобто якщо ми маємо M унітарних матриць U0 через U M мінус
один, всі одного розміру, разом із вектором ймовірностей, то якщо ми беремо зважене середнє каналів,
що відповідають окремим унітарним матрицям, як показано тут на екрані, ми отримаємо канал. і канали,
які можна записати таким чином, називаються змішаними унітарними каналами. не кожен канал є змішаним унітарним каналом: ми не можемо отримати
таким чином кожен канал, але вони зустрічаються досить часто. далі розглянемо кілька конкретних
прикладів каналів. це будуть приклади каналів від одного qubit до одного qubit, які називаються qubit-
каналами. перший називається qubit-каналом скидання, і ідея в тому, що цей канал скидає qubit
до нульового стану. тут ми використовуємо велику грецьку літеру лямбда для позначення цього каналу. спосіб запам'ятати, що цей канал робить, —
думати про сферу Блоха: велика лямбда схожа на стрілку, що вказує вгору, а нульовий стан знаходиться у верхній точці сфери Блоха. тому це ніби
вказівка на місцезнаходження виходу. математично він визначається так: лямбда від ро дорівнює сліду ро, помноженому на |0⟩⟨0|. тому
якщо ми обчислимо його для будь-якої матриці густини ро, ми отримаємо нульовий стан як матрицю густини. природно запитати,
навіщо нам слід. хіба не можна просто визначити лямбда від ро як |0⟩⟨0| без сліду ро попереду?
відповідь: ні. канали повинні бути лінійними відображеннями, і без сліду ро воно не буде лінійним. також пам'ятай,
що іноді нам потрібно знати, як канал працює як лінійне відображення на входах, що не є матрицями густини. наприклад, як ми
бачили раніше, якщо ми хочемо знати, що канал робить, коли ми застосовуємо його до складеної системи, нам потрібно
обчислити цей канал для окремих блоків більшої блокової матриці. і хоча вся блокова матриця може бути
матрицею густини, окремі блоки загалом не будуть. тому подивімося, що саме цей канал робить, коли ми застосовуємо його
лише до однієї частини складеної системи, і конкретніше — що він робить, коли ми застосовуємо його до одного з двох qubit'ів,
що утворюють ebit. якщо точніше, припустімо, що A і B — qubit'и, які як пара перебувають у стані Белла Ф+, і ми застосовуємо лямбда
до, скажімо, першого qubit'у A. щоб з'ясувати, що відбудеться, спочатку виразимо стан Ф+ як матрицю густини і
для цього прикладу використаємо нотацію Дірака. ось стан Ф+ як квантовий вектор стану, і ось що ми отримуємо, коли
множимо цей вектор на спряжений транспонований і розгортаємо. потім ми застосовуємо канал до першого qubit'у та обчислюємо результат. ось
лямбда, застосоване до першого qubit'у, і ось що ми отримуємо при обчисленні кожного доданка: слід |0⟩⟨0| дорівнює одиниці,
і слід |1⟩⟨1| теж. тому в цих двох випадках вихід каналу — |0⟩⟨0|. це пояснює
два доданки у відповіді. слід |0⟩⟨1|, з іншого боку, дорівнює нулю, так само як і слід |1⟩⟨0|,
тому ці два доданки дорівнюють нулю і нічого не додають до відповіді. тепер можемо трохи спростити,
і ми отримаємо нульовий стан для першого qubit'у A та повністю змішаний стан для
другого qubit'у B. зверни увагу зокрема на те, що ми не отримали стан Ф+ для B, що не було б поганим здогадом,
якби ми нічого не знали про матриці густини і просто дивилися на представлення стану квантовим вектором стану. але це
не те, як працює цей канал, і немає жодного каналу, який міг би працювати таким чином. канал лямбда називається qubit-каналом скидання, але
насправді він більше схожий на викидання вхідного qubit'у і заміну його свіжим qubit'ом у нульовому стані. але це насправді
єдиний qubit-канал, що завжди виводить нульовий стан. ось ще один приклад qubit-каналу, відомого як
повністю дефазуючий канал. він позначається дельтою, і він залишає діагональні
елементи будь-якої матриці 2×2 без змін та обнуляє позадіагональні елементи. дельта — грецький еквівалент латинської літери D,
що є скороченням від diagonal («діагональний»). це один зі способів запам'ятати, що робить цей канал. ми також можемо
виразити цей канал у нотації Дірака, як показано на екрані. і, щоб бути точним, вихід
завжди є матрицею 2×2. зокрема, два нульових виходи означають нульову матрицю 2×2. ми часто так робимо,
і це ми вже бачили в цій серії: символ нуль загалом використовується, можливо неоднозначно, щоб позначати нульовий
елемент будь-якого об'єкта — числа, вектора, матриці тощо. зробімо те саме, що ми робили раніше для
qubit-каналу скидання, і подивімось, що відбудеться, якщо ми застосуємо цей канал до половини ebit'у. налаштування те саме, тому я не буду
повторювати цю частину. результат — стан, показаний на екрані, що по суті є спільним випадковим бітом. тобто
цей канал фактично перетворив ebit на ідеально корельовану пару класичних випадкових бітів.
це узгоджується з більш загальною інтерпретацією цього каналу: обнулюючи позадіагональні елементи матриці густини, ми фактично
викидаємо квантову складову матриці густини, залишаючи діагональну матрицю густини, що представляє
класичний імовірнісний стан. інший спосіб подивитися на це: цей канал представляє ідеальний безшумний класичний канал, що передає біт.
тож якщо ми подаємо нульовий стан, одиничний стан або опуклу комбінацію цих двох станів, то цей стан виходить незмінним. але якщо ти намагаєшся
подати квантовий стан, наприклад стан плюс, то це ніби канал вимірює цей стан вимірюванням у стандартному базисі, а потім
передає класичний результат. останній приклад qubit-каналу — це повністю деполяризуючий канал.
цей канал завжди видає повністю змішаний стан. тому він у певному сенсі схожий на qubit-канал скидання,
за винятком того, що ми отримуємо менш корисний повністю змішаний стан замість ініціалізованого qubit'у. природний спосіб
думати про цей канал: він представляє екстремальну форму шуму, і що стосується qubit-каналів —
гучнішого за це не буває. у мене немає хорошого мнемонічного прийому для запам'ятовування того, що цей канал робить, хіба що омега —
остання літера грецького алфавіту, яка іноді асоціюється з кінцем всього. і можливо, саме це і відбувається
WEBVTT
з усіма qubit'ами зрештою. що стосується шуму, це досить екстремально. але одне, що ми можемо зробити, — це розглянути опуклу
комбінацію цього каналу та тотожного каналу з, можливо, малою ймовірністю епсилон для повної
деполяризації. це менш екстремальна форма шуму, де заданий стан qubit'у здебільшого залишається незмінним, але є
невелика ймовірність, що він стане повністю змішаним. геометрично ми можемо думати про це як про незначне стискання сфери Блоха до центру.
до речі, ми можемо зробити щось подібне і з повністю дефазуючим каналом, щоб моделювати, наприклад, процес декогерентності, коли речі
стають дещо більш класичними через якийсь процес. тож ось три базові приклади qubit-каналів. ми
повернемося до них головним чином як до джерела прикладів протягом решти уроку. далі ми обговоримо математичні
представлення каналів, починаючи з базового питання. лінійні відображення з векторів у вектори завжди можна
представити матрицями у знайомий спосіб: дія лінійного відображення описується матричним
множенням вектора. але канали — це лінійні відображення з матриць у матриці, а не з векторів у вектори. тому
загалом як ми можемо виразити канали математично? іноді для спеціальних каналів буде проста формула,
що їх описує, — і так було в прикладах qubit-каналів, які ми вже обговорили. але це
непрактично загалом, оскільки не завжди буде така гарна формула. для порівняння: у спрощеному
формулюванні квантової інформації ми використовуємо унітарні матриці для представлення операцій над квантовими векторами стану.
кожна унітарна матриця представляє дійсну операцію, і кожну дійсну операцію можна виразити як унітарну матрицю. тому
по суті це питання про те, як ми робимо це для каналів. відповідь: насправді існує кілька способів представити
канали математично. зокрема, ми обговоримо три різні способи представлення каналів,
названих на честь трьох людей, чия робота відіграла важливу роль у їх розвитку: Штайнспрінга, Краусса і Чоя.
спочатку ми побачимо, як ці різні представлення працюють, а потім у останній частині уроку побачимо, як три представлення пов'язані, і
зокрема як ми можемо переходити між ними. ми також побачимо, що ці представлення точно відображають вимоги до каналів,
а саме що вони є лінійними відображеннями і завжди перетворюють матриці густини на матриці густини, навіть коли
вони застосовані лише до частини складеної системи. першими йдуть представлення Штайнспрінга. Вільям Форест Штайнспрінг
був математиком, який не займався квантовою інформацією, і представлення Штайнспрінга, як я їх опишу,
є в певному сенсі похідною від його роботи з теорії операторів 1950-х років. але ця робота безсумнівно
була важливою частиною розвитку математики, на якій базуються квантові канали. ідея за цим способом представлення каналів полягає в тому, що кожен
канал може бути реалізований певним чином, який я зараз опишу. спочатку ми формуємо складену систему, що складається з
входу до того каналу, який реалізуємо, разом з ініціалізованою робочою системою. потім
унітарна операція виконується над складеною системою, і нарешті та частина отриманої складеної системи,
що відповідає виходу каналу, залишається або виводиться, а решта відкидається або відслідковується. корисно
виразити це у вигляді діаграми, і найпростіше почати зі спеціального випадку, де вхідна та
вихідна системи однакові. ця діаграма, до речі, схожа на діаграму квантового circuit'у, за винятком того, що дроти
представляють довільні системи, а не обов'язково окремі qubit'и. тому ми починаємо з вхідної системи X у стані
ро, вводимо ініціалізовану робочу систему W. на цій діаграмі я припускаю, що нуль є класичним
станом W, і беремо |0⟩ як ініціалізований стан системи. але ми можемо альтернативно зафіксувати будь-який чистий стан
W і вважати його ініціалізованим станом. потім ми виконуємо якусь унітарну операцію над парою WX, а потім
обчислюємо часткового сліду від робочої системи та виводимо X. на діаграмі, до речі, я використовую символ заземлення з
електротехніки, щоб вказати, що W відкидається. це необов'язково стандартний символ, і ти не
знайдеш його в Qiskit — там ти просто ігноруєш qubit'и, які тебе не цікавлять. головне — я просто хочу мати символ, який чітко
показує, що ми відкидаємо систему для цілей цього обговорення. загалом нам не обов'язково потрібно, щоб
вхідна та вихідна системи були однаковими. тому ми можемо мати, наприклад, вихідну систему Y разом із системою сміття
G, яка відслідковується. щоб U було унітарним, воно повинно бути квадратною матрицею, тому є припущення,
що пара GY разом має таку ж кількість класичних станів, що й пара WX. наприклад, ці системи
можуть складатися з qubit'ів: вхідна система X — з 5 qubit'ів, а W — скажімо, з 10 qubit'ів. тоді U — унітарна
операція на 15 qubit'ах. тоді Y може складатися лише з чотирьох qubit'ів, а значить G — з 11 qubit'ів.
або, можливо, це не qubit'и взагалі. важливо лише те, щоб WX разом і GY разом мали однакову кількість
класичних станів, щоб U міг бути унітарним. опис каналу такого вигляду називається представленням Штайнспрінга каналу. тепер
досить просто довести, що будь-яке відображення фі, яке можна описати таким чином, є насправді дійсним каналом.
зокрема, якщо ми починаємо з матриці густини, а потім додаємо додаткову робочу систему, ми безумовно
залишимось із матрицею густини. ми вже зазначили, що застосування унітарної операції дає нам дійсний канал.
і якщо ми маємо матрицю густини складеної системи і обчислюємо частковий слід однієї з систем, ми знову залишимось із матрицею густини. тому при
композиції цих кроків ми гарантовано завжди отримаємо перетворення матриць густини на матриці густини. і це також лінійно.
наразі зовсім неясно, що кожен канал справді може бути реалізований таким чином для деякого вибору
робочої системи та системи сміття, а також унітарної операції U. але це правда, і ми
побачимо чому наприкінці уроку. ось приклад представлення Штайнспрінга для повністю дефазуючого
qubit-каналу. і щоб бути точним, тут дроти — це qubit'и, і це звичайний gate CNOT.
все дуже просто: вхідний qubit знаходиться зверху, і ми ввели робочий qubit, ініціалізований до нульового
стану. потім виконуємо операцію CNOT, де вхідний qubit є управляючим, а робочий qubit —
цільовим, після чого від робочого qubit'у обчислюємо частковий слід. інтуїтивно зрозуміло,
що це реалізує повністю дефазуючий канал, оскільки gate CNOT ніби діє як вимірювання у стандартному базисі над верхнім
qubit'ом, копіюючи його класичний стан на нижній qubit, після чого результат викидається.
але ми також можемо провести обчислення, і, звичайно, це гарна ідея — робити так, оскільки ми справді
WEBVTT
не повинні надто довіряти своїй інтуїції. ми можемо почати із записування представлення матрицею густини
двох qubit'ів після того, як робочий qubit введено. зверни увагу, що ми використовуємо конвенцію впорядкування qubit'ів,
де нижній qubit — лівий, а верхній — правий. ми можемо явно виразити цю матрицю густини
як реальну матрицю 4×4, як показано на екрані, а потім обчислюємо ефект,
який gate CNOT має на цю матрицю густини. тобто ми кон'югуємо унітарною матрицею, пов'язаною з цим
gate'ом, знову пам'ятаючи про конвенцію впорядкування qubit'ів. тому це правильна унітарна
матриця, і результат показано тут. фактично gate CNOT
переставив елементи нашої початкової матриці. тепер потенційно ненульові елементи знаходяться в
чотирьох кутах. залишається обчислити частковий слід, і ми могли б зробити це безпосередньо з матриці, але
альтернатива — перейти до нотації Дірака, як показано на екрані, і тоді стає досить просто обчислити,
що відбувається, коли ми обчислюємо частковий слід від лівого qubit'у в кожному доданку. результат такий, що виживають лише
доданки, що відповідають діагональним елементам ро. тому ми дефазували qubit, як
і очікувалося. як завжди, перевір це самостійно у власному темпі, якщо хочеш. це хороший
приклад для практики роботи з матрицями густини та частковими
слідами. це не єдиний спосіб реалізувати повністю дефазуючий канал. ось альтернативне представлення Штайнспрінга для цього
каналу. я не буду детально обчислювати в цьому відео, але покажу його коротко на випадок, якщо ти захочеш поставити відео на паузу і
розглянути уважніше. принцип дії схожий на перший, але деталі
відрізняються. цього разу ми починаємо з gate'у Hadamard на робочому qubit'і, що переводить його у стан плюс. і якщо
ми розгортаємо тензорний добуток, ми отримуємо матрицю, показану на екрані. щоб застосувати gate CZ, ми
кон'югуємо відповідною унітарною матрицею, і результат цього полягає у введенні деяких знаків мінус у
матрицю. зокрема, останній рядок і останній стовпець обидва множаться на −1.
і цього разу було б досить незручно переходити до нотації Дірака, тому ми обчислимо частковий слід
безпосередньо. коли ми обчислюємо частковий слід від першого з двох qubit'ів, ми отримуємо суму двох діагональних блоків 2×2,
і кінцевий результат знову такий, що ми дефазували qubit. це було швидко. і якщо ти не
звик до таких обчислень, не поспішай і роби це повільно. швидкість тут не важлива.
щоб завершити цей приклад, зазначу, що за цією реалізацією стоїть досить проста ідея,
яка досить наочно виражена в останньому кроці обчислення, яке ми щойно промайнули. коротший спосіб сказати це:
якщо ми усереднюємо задану матрицю густини qubit'у з тією ж матрицею густини, кон'югованою матрицею Паулі Z, то
це те ж саме, що дефазувати. тому повністю дефазуючий канал виявляється змішаним унітарним
каналом, де ми або нічого не робимо (тобто виконуємо тотожну операцію), або виконуємо gate Z, кожне
з імовірністю 1/2. добре знати. тому підсумовуючи, ми маємо два різних
представлення Штайнспрінга повністю дефазуючого каналу. це говорить нам про щось важливе: представлення Штайнспрінга
не є унікальними, і насправді їх нескінченно багато для будь-якого заданого каналу. далі ми обговоримо представлення Краусса
каналів, які дають нам зручний формульний спосіб виразити канали через матричне
множення та додавання. представлення Краусса названі на честь Карла Краусса — фізика, який, серед іншого,
розробив багато базових математичних деталей каналів та загального формулювання квантової інформації ширше. загалом
представлення Краусса — це вираження каналу, що має вигляд, показаний тут на екрані. зокрема, ми маємо
набір матриць, які тут названі A0 через A N мінус один для деякого натурального числа N. вони визначають
дію каналу на будь-який заданий вхід ро згідно з формулою. коротко: ми кон'югуємо ро кожною з цих матриць,
які в цьому контексті часто називають матрицями Краусса, а потім підсумовуємо результат — це і дає нам вихід. всі ці матриці повинні мати
однакові розміри, і зокрема їх стовпці повинні відповідати класичним станам вхідної системи, а
рядки — класичним станам вихідної системи. якщо це так, то при обчисленні добутку AK * ро * AK дагер для будь-якого
K ми отримуємо квадратну матрицю, рядки та стовпці якої відповідають класичним станам вихідної системи.
тому має сенс, що вираз породжує матрицю густини вихідної системи. але не кожен довільний вибір цих матриць Краусса
дає нам дійсний канал. однак є досить проста
умова на матриці, що гарантує дійсний канал. і ця умова — формула, показана тут.
зокрема, якщо ми підсумовуємо добутки AK дагер * AK по всіх значеннях K,
ми повинні отримати тотожну матрицю. і це буде тотожна матриця, рядки та стовпці якої відповідають
класичним станам вхідної системи. отже, ця умова повинна виконуватися, щоб відображення, задане
першим рівнянням, було дійсним каналом. і виявляється, що кожен канал справді має представлення такого
вигляду, якщо взяти достатньо велике N. ось кілька прикладів представлень Краусса,
починаючи з qubit-каналу скидання. ми можемо отримати представлення Краусса для цього каналу, використовуючи
дві матриці Краусса: |0⟩⟨0| та |0⟩⟨1|. тому N рівне двом у цьому прикладі.
ми можемо підставити ці вибори в загальну формулу і маємо лише два доданки, тому суму легко записати.
і якщо спростити та впізнати, що вираз у дужках — це слід ро, ми бачимо, що отримуємо
qubit-канал скидання. ми також можемо перевірити, що необхідна умова на ці матриці виконується. це просто питання підстановки матриць Краусса
у рівняння та обчислення. і ми отримуємо тотожну матрицю, як і вимагається. для іншого прикладу розглянемо знову
повністю дефазуючий канал. взяття матриць |0⟩⟨0| та |1⟩⟨1| спрацьовує, що можна перевірити,
розгорнувши суму та досить безпосередньо переконавшись, що ми отримуємо потрібне. і знову необхідна умова виконується. ще одна
альтернатива — взяти A0 рівним тотожній матриці, поділеній на √2, та A1 рівним
матриці Паулі Z, поділеній на √2. і якщо ми обчислимо, то знову отримаємо повністю дефазуючий канал, на основі спостереження,
WEBVTT
яке ми зробили про цей канал трохи раніше в уроці. і знову необхідна умова досить просто
перевіряється як вправа, якщо ти вважаєш це корисним. розглянемо повністю деполяризуючий
канал, що видає повністю змішаний стан для кожного вхідного значення матриці густини. для нього потрібно чотири матриці Краусса:
представлення Краусса з N рівним трьом або менше отримати неможливо. ось один вибір, що спрацьовує,
а ось інший. тому вправа — перевірити, що ці вибори спрацьовують, а також що необхідна умова
виконується. варто зазначити, що другий варіант по суті говорить, що можна повністю деполяризувати qubit, або іншими словами повністю
випадковізувати його, випадково обравши одну з чотирьох матриць Паулі, включно з тотожною, і застосувавши
відповідну унітарну операцію до qubit'у. тому повністю деполяризуючий канал — ще один приклад змішаного
унітарного каналу. останнє з трьох представлень каналів, які ми розглянемо, — це представлення Чоя. Манду Чой —
математик, що займається теорією матриць та іншими темами. представлення Чоя названо на його честь
за його елегантну статтю 1975 року, яка в певному сенсі пов'язує все це разом. представлення Чоя
каналу фі — це одна матриця, яку прийнято позначати Jфі. і зокрема, якщо
вхідна система має N класичних станів, а вихідна система — M класичних станів, то представлення Чоя фі буде
квадратною матрицею N*M на N*M. перш ніж точно розказати, як визначається матриця, хочу згадати кілька
її ключових властивостей, які мотивують це представлення способом, яким саме визначення, можливо, не мотивує — принаймні на
перший погляд. по-перше, на відміну від представлень Штайнспрінга і Краусса, представлення Чоя
є так званим вірним представленням, що означає: кожен канал має рівно одне таке представлення. це досить важливо,
оскільки говорить нам, що два канали є однаковими тоді і тільки тоді, коли їхні представлення Чоя однакові. тому якщо
ти маєш два різних описи каналів — наприклад два різних представлення Штайнспрінга, або два різних представлення Краусса, або, можливо, одне
з кожного — і хочеш знати, чи є вони фактично одним і тим самим каналом, ти можеш просто обчислити представлення Чоя і
перевірити, чи вони рівні. друга властивість: є прості умови, що перевіряються для представлення Чоя, які є істинними тоді і тільки тоді,
коли ми маємо дійсний канал. ця властивість не така особлива — те саме можна сказати й про два інших представлення, але це добра властивість,
і ми обговоримо її детальніше незабаром. ще одна річ, яку варто зазначити про представлення Чоя: хоча ми представляємо
канал матрицею, ця матриця не представляє канал безпосередньо як лінійне відображення. насправді
природніше пов'язувати представлення Чоя з матрицею густини, що представляє певний стан,
ніж думати про представлення Чоя як про лінійне відображення. однак можна відновити дію каналу з
його представлення Чоя за допомогою досить простої формули, але це не так просто, як звичайне матричне
множення. досить вступних слів. перейдемо до власне визначення. припустімо, що ми маємо канал фі від системи X до системи Y,
і припустімо, що множина класичних станів вхідної системи X — це сигма. нам не потрібно посилатися на множину класичних станів вихідної системи, тому
для визначення її не потрібно називати. представлення Чоя фі тоді визначається виразом,
показаним тут на екрані. маємо суму по всіх класичних станах A та B вхідної системи, і ми
підсумовуємо |a⟩⟨b|, взяте в тензорний добуток з каналом фі, застосованим до |a⟩⟨b|. тому
це представлення визначається формулою. є кілька різних способів думати про цю формулу. перш ніж обговорювати їх,
зазначу, що іноді представлення Чоя визначається дещо інакше, де порядок двох тензорних множників змінений на протилежний. тобто
фі від |a⟩⟨b| стоїть як перший тензорний множник, а не другий. але два різних способи визначення є
еквівалентними з точністю до цієї простої симетрії. але це означає, що при використанні цього представлення краще
уточнити, який порядок ти використовуєш. цей порядок відповідає тому, як це зроблено в Qiskit, і він також кращий для
візуального опису представлення через блокові матриці. тому саме з ним ми і будемо працювати. щоб бути точнішим щодо опису блоковою матрицею:
якщо ми припустімо, що множина класичних станів сигма складається з цілих чисел від нуля до N мінус один
для деякого натурального числа N, то ми можемо альтернативно записати Jфі як блокову матрицю, як показано тут на
екрані. іншими словами, представлення Чоя фі — це матриця, яку ми отримуємо, застосовуючи фі до кожної з
вхідних матриць, що мають рівно один елемент, рівний одиниці, та всі інші елементи нульові, а потім розташовуючи їх
у матрицю досить природним способом. може бути не відразу зрозуміло, навіщо формувати таку матрицю, але
виявляється, що це дуже корисно. одна річ, яку варто зазначити: множина матриць |a⟩⟨b|, де
a і b пробігають по всіх цілих числах від 0 до N мінус один, утворює базис для простору всіх матриць N×N. тому якщо
ти маєш цю матрицю, то за лінійністю ти безумовно можеш визначити, що фі робить з довільною матрицею N×N,
беручи відповідні лінійні комбінації блоків. тому матриця Jфі справді однозначно
визначає фі як лінійне відображення. інший спосіб думати про представлення Чоя каналу —
це те, що воно представляє стан як матрицю густини після нормування. зокрема, поділивши на кількість
класичних станів вхідної системи, яку я продовжуватиму позначати малою літерою N. це завжди дає нам
матрицю густини, яку часто називають станом Чоя каналу. ось як це працює детальніше.
уявімо спочатку, що ми маємо дві ідентичні копії вхідної системи і розглядаємо квантовий вектор стану |ψ⟩,
показаний на екрані, що представляє так званий максимально заплутаний стан цієї пари ідентичних систем. наприклад,
якщо сигма — бінарний алфавіт, то це стан Ф+. але ми можемо думати про аналогічно визначений стан для
будь-якого вибору сигми, і те, що ми отримуємо, — стан, що є дуже сильно заплутаним, і насправді настільки сильно заплутаним, наскільки це можливо
при такому виборі систем. щоб отримати представлення матрицею густини стану, ми множимо вектор стану на спряжений транспонований, як завжди, і
ось як це виглядає. і нарешті, якщо ми думаємо про представлення Чоя каналу, поділене на N, то бачимо, що це стан,
який ми отримали б, застосовуючи канал фі до другої системи. у вигляді рисунку це
виглядає так: ми маємо дві копії системи X у цьому максимально заплутаному стані |ψ⟩. канал фі
застосовується до другої системи, яка знаходиться зверху на діаграмі, і отриманий стан — це стан Чоя фі. звичайно, ми зазвичай не давали б
однакову назву двом різним системам — загалом корисно давати різні назви різним речам. але в даному випадку це має сенс,
WEBVTT
просто щоб встановити цей зв'язок із представленнями Чоя. є кілька наслідків, які ми можемо одразу зробити з цього способу
дивитися на представлення Чоя. по-перше, оскільки стан Чоя є матрицею густини (за умови, що фі —
дійсний канал), ми робимо висновок, що представлення Чоя фі повинне бути напівдодатно визначеним. пам'ятай, що це
вимога до каналів: вони завжди перетворюють матриці густини на матриці густини. і це
лише один спеціальний випадок цього. другий наслідок: якщо ми беремо стан Чоя для будь-якого каналу фі і
потім відкидаємо вихідну систему Y, то ми неодмінно залишимось із повністю змішаним станом на вхідній системі X.
це тому, що застосування каналу до системи, а потім викидання отриманої системи еквівалентно простому викиданню початкової системи.
і якби ми зробили це з нашим максимально заплутаним станом, матрицею густини, яку ми б залишили, була б
тотожна матриця, поділена на N, або іншими словами — повністю змішаний стан для системи X. ідея у більш
математичних термінах: складання будь-якого каналу зі слідом на вихідній системі повинно дорівнювати сліду на
вхідній системі. це тому, що канали зберігають слід через те, що вони є лінійними відображеннями,
що завжди перетворюють матриці густини на матриці густини. якщо ми маємо це рівняння, ми можемо скоротити знаменник N
з обох сторін, щоб отримати дещо простішу умову. словами: обчислення часткового сліду від вихідної системи
представлення Чоя каналу повинно давати нам тотожну матрицю на вхідній системі. тому підсумовуючи: представлення Чоя
каналів завжди напівдодатно визначені, і якщо ми обчислюємо частковий слід від вихідної системи, ми неодмінно
залишаємося з тотожною матрицею на вхідній системі. виявляється, це не лише необхідні умови, але й
достатні. тобто якщо фі — деяке довільне лінійне відображення і обидві умови виконуються,
то фі обов'язково є дійсним каналом. ми побачимо чому це так наприкінці уроку.
розглянемо кілька прикладів, починаючи з повністю дефазуючого каналу. щоб обчислити представлення Чоя, потрібно просто
обчислити формулу. повністю дефазуючий канал залишає |a⟩⟨b| незмінним, коли a рівне b, а інакше вихід —
нуль. тому виживають доданки, де a дорівнює b, і результат виражено на
екрані у нотації Дірака. ми також можемо переглянути це як блокову матрицю. дельта залишає діагональні елементи та обнуляє позадіагональні.
тому ми залишаємось із матрицею, що має одиниці у верхньому лівому та нижньому правому кутах і нулі
в їхніх елементах. це узгоджується з першим виразом. для іншого прикладу розглянемо повністю деполяризуючий канал. знову
починаємо із записування формули, і так само, як у попередньому прикладі, сума не дає внеску,
коли a не рівне b. цього разу, коли a рівне b, ми отримуємо повністю змішаний стан. ми можемо спростити це до
1/2 * тотожна матриця 2×2, взята в тензорний добуток сама з собою, тобто 1/2 * тотожна матриця 4×4.
ми також можемо розглянути це через блокові матриці і, природно, отримаємо той самий результат. і
як останній приклад розглянемо тотожний канал для одного qubit'у. він простий. ось формула, і
тотожний канал нічого не робить. ми можемо думати про результат як про подвоєну матрицю густини, пов'язану зі станом Ф+. це
узгоджується з тим, що ми очікуємо, думаючи про стан Чоя цього каналу. і ось він як блокова матриця. зверни увагу зокрема, що представлення Чоя
тотожного каналу — це не тотожна матриця, а ось ця матриця. ми тепер бачили три різних
способи представляти канали математично, а саме представлення Штайнспрінга, представлення Краусса та представлення Чоя.
ми також маємо визначення каналу: канал — це лінійне відображення, що завжди
перетворює матриці густини на матриці густини, навіть коли канал застосовується лише до частини складеної системи. дуже природне і важливе
питання на цьому етапі: як ми знаємо, що ці речі еквівалентні? наприклад, як ми знаємо, що кожне
відображення, описане будь-яким із цих представлень, є насправді дійсним каналом? і як ми знаємо, що ми не втрачаємо жодних каналів?
решта уроку описує, як все це можна обґрунтувати математично. якщо ти готовий прийняти еквівалентність цих речей і тебе не цікавить, як це можна
обґрунтувати, то можеш пропустити решту відео. але особисто я вважаю, що аргументація
досить витончена, і це гарний приклад особливого стилю математичного доказу, що зустрічається час від часу в теорії квантової інформації. я не буду розглядати
всі деталі: деякі я залишу тобі, або ти можеш знайти їх у письмовому матеріалі до цього уроку, де все розписано
детально. але я сподіваюся представити досить чітку картину того, як це все працює. ми хочемо довести
еквівалентність набору тверджень, і один спосіб зробити це — встановити цикл імплікацій. зокрема, ми почнемо
з визначення каналу, тобто лінійного відображення, що завжди перетворює матриці густини на матриці густини.
з цього визначення ми можемо обґрунтувати, що представлення Чоя цього каналу повинне задовольняти двом умовам, які ми вже
визначили. і фактично ми це вже зробили — це обговорювалося в контексті стану Чоя каналу. потім ми забуваємо
про визначення і працюємо з представленням Чоя: маючи наші дві умови, ми робимо висновок, що для відображення фі обов'язково існує
представлення Краусса. потім ми робимо аналогічну річ: забуваємо про представлення Чоя і працюємо
з довільним представленням Краусса. з нього ми можемо обґрунтувати, що для відображення фі є представлення Штайнспрінга. до речі,
ці аргументи будуть механічними в певному сенсі, що дозволяє нам фактично виконувати перетворення за стрілками для конкретних каналів, якщо ми хочемо
це зробити. остання імплікація — обґрунтувати, що якщо ми маємо представлення Штайнспрінга для відображення фі, то
це відображення обов'язково є дійсним каналом. і це ми вже зробили — цього разу в контексті представлень Штайнспрінга.
загалом ці чотири імплікації доводять еквівалентність цих чотирьох речей, оскільки ти можеш почати з будь-якої з них і
транзитивно слідувати імплікаціям до будь-якої іншої. ми почнемо з першої імплікації,
яка полягає в тому, що якщо ми маємо канал фі (лінійне відображення, що завжди перетворює матриці густини на матриці густини), то він має представлення Чоя,
що задовольняє двом умовам, які ми визначили раніше: воно є напівдодатно визначеним
і якщо ми обчислюємо частковий слід від вихідної системи, ми отримуємо тотожну матрицю на вхідній. і як я вже зазначив,
ми вже розглянули цю імплікацію в контексті станів Чоя. зокрема, коли ми ділимо представлення Чоя каналу на N (кількість
класичних станів вхідної системи), ми отримуємо матрицю густини. більш того, редукований стан
вхідної системи X для цього стану є повністю змішаним станом, або іншими словами — тотожною матрицею, поділеною на N. скорочення знаменника дає нам наші
дві умови. тому ця імплікація досить швидка та легка, оскільки ми вже її розглянули.
WEBVTT
тепер розглянемо другу імплікацію. цього разу ми починаємо з представлення Чоя відображення,
яке, як ми припускаємо, задовольняє двом вимогам. і наша мета — знайти представлення Краусса для цього відображення,
що задовольняє вимозі, яку ми обговорили раніше. ця імплікація є досить механічною. нам знадобиться
трохи лінійної алгебри, і все зводиться в основному до маніпуляцій із матрицями та векторами досить кмітливим
способом. починається з припущення, що представлення Чоя є напівдодатно визначеним — це перша з двох вимог, які ми припускаємо
виконаними. поняття напівдодатно визначеної матриці є фундаментально важливим у квантовій інформації — і не лише в контексті матриць густини.
воно абсолютно критичне тут: без нього ми не змогли б зробити це. зокрема, припущення,
що Jфі є напівдодатно визначеною, дозволяє нам виразити її у формі, показаній на екрані, для деякого вибору
векторів |s0⟩ через |sN−1⟩ та деякого натурального числа N. і зазначу явно, що ці вектори
не обов'язково є одиничними. один спосіб отримати такий вираз — скористатися спектральною теоремою для напівдодатно
визначених матриць, яка обговорювалася в попередньому уроці. тут ми не бачимо власних значень, що з'являються явно, як у спектральному
розкладанні, але пам'ятай, що власні значення напівдодатно визначених матриць завжди є невід'ємними дійсними числами. і також пам'ятай, що ми
не вимагаємо від цих векторів |s0⟩ через |sN−1⟩ бути одиничними. тому ми можемо взяти квадратні корені з
власних значень і помножити їх на одиничні власні вектори зі спектрального розкладання, щоб отримати ці
вектори |s0⟩ через |sN−1⟩. насправді для цього доказу не важливо, щоб ці вектори були ортогональними. це
справді випливає зі спектрального розкладання, але ми не будемо цим користуватися тут. якби у нас був якийсь інший вираз Jфі такого вигляду, що не випливає зі спектральної
теореми, то це теж підійшло б. тепер розкладемо кожен із цих векторів, як показано на екрані.
це подібно до того, що ми робили б, якби ці вектори були квантовими векторами стану пари систем XY, і ми виконували б
вимірювання у стандартному базисі над системою X. щоб бути точним, ми нічого не вимірюємо — ми просто записуємо ці вектори в такій формі, що
завжди можливо. і тут настає трюк: ми визначаємо матриці Краусса A0 через AN−1, відриваючи
|a⟩ від початку цих векторів |s0⟩ через |sN−1⟩, перетворюючи їх на ⟨a| замість |a⟩
і ставлячи праворуч, як показано в рівнянні на екрані. один спосіб думати про це:
ми по суті «складаємо» ці вектори, щоб утворити матриці, так що якби ми склали стовпці AK один на одного, то
отримали б назад |sk⟩. тому ці матриці мають точно ті самі елементи, що й відповідні вектори, але ми просто
переставили елементи, щоб отримати матриці. ми також можемо думати про ці матриці суто символічно у нотації Дірака,
як записано тут. і зараз виникає очевидне питання: чому це має спрацьовувати? ну, не зупиняймось надто на
тому, чому це спрацьовує. просто перевіримо, що це так. для цього визначимо нове відображення — те, що задається
цими матрицями, де ми розглядаємо їх як матриці Краусса. тепер ми можемо обчислити представлення Чоя
цього нового відображення і побачимо, що воно рівне представленню Чоя відображення фі, з якого ми починали. і
оскільки представлення Чоя є вірними, це означає, що два відображення насправді рівні. я не буду розглядати алгебру в цьому відео —
ти можеш перевірити це самостійно. це досить механічно і є гарною практикою, і все потрібне для цього є прямо
тут на екрані. ми ще нічого не сказали про дві другі умови в двох рамках, але вони
виявляються еквівалентними. і один спосіб встановити це — перевірити рівняння, показане тут внизу
екрана. літера T тут, до речі, означає транспонування матриці, що ти можеш альтернативно думати як
лінійне відображення, що перетворює |a⟩⟨b| на |b⟩⟨a|. і це просто щось потрібне, щоб формула працювала. тому
підсумовуючи: для цієї імплікації безперечно потрібна деяка алгебра, але, як я вже казав, вона досить механічна —
свого роду жонглювання індексами, як деякі люди це називають. але якщо ти опрацюєш це і дозволиш своєму мозку засвоїти, то можеш виявити,
що приходиш до кращого розуміння того, як представлення Чоя та представлення Краусса пов'язані. третя імплікація дозволяє нам
перейти від представлення Краусса відображення фі (де звичайна умова виконана) до представлення Штайнспрінга. ця імплікація досить
схожа духом на попередню в тому сенсі, що вона механічна і може бути переглянута та перевірена суто алгебраїчно. ідея
насправді досить проста: ми беремо наші матриці Краусса і формуємо частину більшої матриці, складаючи
їх одна на одну, як показано на екрані. як тільки буде заповнено, це дасть нам унітарну матрицю U для
представлення Штайнспрінга. унітарні матриці повинні бути квадратними, тому нам доведеться дозаповнити стільки
стовпців, скільки потрібно. але насправді не має значення, якими вони будуть, аби ми отримали унітарну
матрицю. якщо на мить відкласти питання про те, що U є унітарною, і зосередитись лише на лінійному відображенні, що задається
представленням Штайнспрінга, яке ми отримуємо з цієї матриці U, то ми виявимо, що це відображення рівне
початковому відображенню фі, визначеному представленням Краусса, з якого ми починали. це ще одна частина доказу, яку я не буду розглядати в цьому відео. ти можеш
знайти деталі в письмовому матеріалі до цього уроку. але ти також можеш захотіти приділити час і опрацювати це самостійно. просто пам'ятай,
як завжди для цієї серії, що ми використовуємо конвенцію впорядкування qubit'ів для інтерпретації діаграми: W і G відповідають
тензорним множникам з лівого боку в рівняннях. і до речі, якщо ти
опрацюєш це, то виявиш, що оскільки у нас є |0⟩⟨0| як тензорний множник з лівого боку в рівнянні,
яке нам потрібно перевірити, єдина частина U, що має значення, — це та, що задана матрицями Краусса. тому аби ми
заповнили стовпці U так, щоб вона була унітарною, ми готові. але, звичайно, це вимагає, щоб стовпці, утворені A0 через AN−1,
складені один на одного, були ортонормованими. і саме тут вступає умова, яку ми висуваємо до представлень Краусса.
і це справді точний еквівалент ортонормованості стовпців. відповідні математичні співвідношення, необхідні для
цього висновку, показані внизу екрана. тому постав відео на паузу і перевір, якщо хочеш. або знову ж
зверніться до письмового матеріалу для детальнішого ознайомлення. коротко: те, що відбувається тут — як у цій імплікації, так і в
попередній — це опис однакових математичних операцій різними, але еквівалентними способами.
«биттям серця» всього цього по суті є матричне множення. четверта і фінальна імплікація встановлює, що якщо ми маємо
представлення Штайнспрінга для деякого відображення, то це відображення обов'язково є дійсним каналом. і, як я зазначив
раніше, ми вже розглянули цю імплікацію, коли обговорювали представлення Штайнспрінга. підсумовуючи та
WEBVTT
трохи іншими словами: введення ініціалізованої робочої системи є дійсним каналом. це тому, що тензорне множення фіксованої
матриці густини на задану матрицю густини завжди дає матрицю густини, і це лінійне відображення за білінійністю
тензорних добутків. унітарні операції завжди є дійсними каналами, як я обговорював раніше в уроці. обчислення часткового сліду від системи є дійсним каналом, оскільки
частковий слід — це лінійне відображення, що завжди перетворює матриці густини на матриці густини. і нарешті, композиції
каналів завжди є каналами, що досить просто, але безперечно заслуговує окремого спостереження. і з
чотирма імплікаціями, які ми щойно розглянули, ми встановили еквівалентність наших трьох представлень каналів разом із
початковим визначенням каналу. зокрема, ми почали з визначення каналу і побачили, як це визначення передбачає, що його представлення Чоя
обов'язково задовольняє двом базовим умовам. потім ми побачили, як ці умови дозволяють нам знайти представлення Краусса, яке своєю чергою
дозволяє нам знайти представлення Штайнспрінга. і нарешті, ми побачили, що існування представлення Штайнспрінга виявляє, що ми насправді
маємо дійсний канал. звичайно, там є технічні деталі, і це не обов'язково просто, особливо
коли ти бачиш це вперше. але що цікаво і варто уваги: ці імплікації побудовані таким чином, що насправді роблять
речі настільки простими, наскільки можливо. і в математиці ніколи не варто соромитись іти найлегшим шляхом.
наприклад, зовсім не очевидно, що кожен канал має представлення Штайнспрінга або представлення Краусса.
але відносно легко зробити висновок, що представлення Чоя кожного каналу задовольняє двом умовам, які ми з ним пов'язали. і це
дозволяє нам слідувати більш-менш алгебраїчним шляхом до двох інших представлень. аналогічно,
остання імплікація — від представлення Штайнспрінга назад до визначення — також відносно пряма, і
дозволяє нам зробити висновок, що ми отримуємо лише канали, а не інші відображення, з представлень Чоя за умови, що
необхідні умови виконані. і, як я натякав раніше, спосіб, яким ми обґрунтовуємо ці імплікації, є достатньо механічним, щоб дозволити нам легко переходити
між представленнями. і якщо ти повернешся до деяких прикладів, які ми розглянули раніше в уроці, то виявиш, що насправді можна
переходити між представленнями іноді досить легко і безпосередньо. і це кінець
уроку, який був повністю про канали. ми поговорили про те, що вони собою являють, і розглянули деякі базові приклади. ми обговорили три способи, якими канали можна
представити, і заглибились у деякі технічні деталі, що встановлюють еквівалентність цих представлень.
сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене на наступному уроці, який буде присвячений вимірюванням у загальному формулюванні квантової інформації. до зустрічі!